ce trudeau bonjour arrêt dans une usine
à montréal l'économie évidemment ça
impose comme le thème de cette campagne
c'est pas un pari risqué vous avez fait
hier de dire aux canadiens
moi je vais faire trois années
difficiles de suite peut noter les cieux
parce qu'on voit réinvestir extrêmement
dangereux dire c'est d'abord une
question de dire la vérité on est en
déficit actuellement notre économie ne
roule pas aussi bien qu'elle devrait les
gens ont besoin d'investissements les
gens ont besoin d'emplois
c'est un moment justement pour investir
et de miser sur nos citoyens notre
avenir
étiez vous obligé d'aller aussi loin en
disant jusqu'en 2019 j'aurais pu dire
prochaines années c'est sûr qu'on est en
déficit comme vous le dites prix du
pétrole c'est évident mais trois ans
c'est beaucoup c'est presque mandat
mes décisions qui les choix que je fais
sont basés sur ce dont on a besoin c'est
pas basé sur qu'est-ce que je peux
vendre de façon politique
les gens sont tannés d'un gouvernement
depuis dix ans qui beaucoup plus
intéressés à sa propre réussite
politique qui a bien gouverné c'est pour
ça que depuis dix ans on a vu un échec
total du plan de m alors moi je préfère
dire voilà notre plan voilà comment nous
allons équilibrer le budget en créant de
la croissance économique qui va venir de
l'investissement dont nous avons besoin
et vous dit pour sa part exemple les
infrastructures il faut mettre le paquet
vous vous ajoutez vous d'oubli presse
que les conservateurs auraient fait vous
allez même plus loin que le npd
pourquoi c'est essentiel maintenant de
mettre autant d'argent parce que les
conversations que j'hérite les canadiens
sont très très clairs les gens sont
inquiets pour leur retraite sont
inquiets pour l'investissement à dans la
route dans le transport collectif qui
vont leur rendre au travail
elles sont préoccupés des emplois de
leurs enfants et le
coût de la vie on a besoin justement
puisqu'on est en récession maintenant de
créer cette opportunité pour tenter pour
faire croître l'économie
les gens vont vous dire mais justement
c'est ce qui collait à la peau
on remonte très loin au régime de votre
père de dépenser sans regarder mais
c'est pas grave
allons-y ballon si c'est pas ça le
danger politique de ce que vous avez
choisi moi si je me préoccupais
énormément de comparer à mon père
j'aurais tout une autre approche le
moins je suis concentré sur ce dont on a
besoin aujourd'hui et pour demain
ainsi comme ça que j'ai rassemblé une
équipe extraordinaire c'est comme ça
qu'on est en train de faire le plein et
je voyais pas le martin tout à l'heure
donc vous êtes allé chercher le champion
du déficit zéro
il lui même vous appuyez en disant ce
n'est pas ce que je vais pas mettre des
mots dans sa bouche mais est ce que ça
faisait que ce n'est pas si grave vous
dit de faire des déficits de 3
il faut comprendre le contexte le
contexte très différent notre ratio
dette pib était énorme dans les années
90 et sur sa cause est énormément
tropicale elle réduire maintenant notre
ratio dette/pib et et 30 % et 15 mois le
meilleur dans nos cd on a des avantages
maintenant à pouvoir investir pour créer
ces opportunités ça fait trop longtemps
que nos routes nos ponts et nos
logements sociaux sont sont en train de
s'écrouler
ça prend un gouvernement qui va miser
sur notre avenir
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement pour comprendre si la
grande région de montréal par exemple
est ce que ça veut dire du financement
fédéral accrue pour des grands projets
de transport ou de route qu'est ce que
ça veut qu'est ce que ça change pour la
vie des gens qui vous écoutent à une des
choses que ça va changer c'est que le
gouvernement va pas est entré au fédéral
va pas est en train d'annoncer le projet
qui veut parce que c'est un compte et
qui pensent gagner
nous on veut des partenaires c'est les
communautés locales c'est les gens dans
mon comté de papineau
c'est les gens à aux différents paliers
de gouvernements qu'ils savent c'est
quoi les besoins
nous le fédéral on devrait être lent
tant que partenaire et pas pour dire
vous devez faire ceci vous devez faire
cela ça veut dire plus d'argent que ça
veut dire plus d'argent pour à des
logements abordables plus de résidences
pour l'un de nous et n'est plus
d'investissements en métro en train de
banlieue
si vous êtes le prix à payer pour ça je
regarde les canadiens devraient les y
oblige j'avais vous aurez temps dévissé
de 3,6 à me tuer politiquement ce
programme je suis honnête si votre pari
oui c'est mon pari que les canadiens
méritent d'avant des politiques qui leur
disent la vérité monsieur mulcair est en
train d'offrir des coupures au lieu
d'investissement création d'emplois et
prospérité à la réalité c'est que ça si
c'est désolant pour moi je peux pas
imaginer comment les candidats du npd
vont aller faire du porte à porte pour
expliquer aux gens non on voit pas
investir dans votre communauté
on va on va faire un équilibre
budgétaire immédiatement à tout prix
c'est le plan afin si le monde à
l'envers monsieur très dur où le npd qui
sur certains aspects un peu plus à
droite que vous vous le prenez sur sa
gauche alors je veux tester trois mots
avec vous et coalition avec le npd s'il
vous manque et où il manquait monsieur
molière des sièges pour avoir un
gouvernement gouvernable est ce que vous
seriez ouvert une coalition d'abord je
suis très content de pouvoir dire que
pendant une élection ainsi que les chefs
qui vont choisir quel sera le prochain
gouvernement si les canadiens font
choisir et j'ai énormément confiance
dans leurs votes
deuxièmement après 10 ans de souvenirs
un peu ce dont les gens ont besoin c'est
pas juste un gouvernement différent
c'est un meilleur gouvernement et que
monsieur milles carrés choisi de suivre
la ligne du plan économique de monsieur
harper pour l'austérité des coupures
plutôt que de dire non on veut miser sur
la classe moyenne on veut réduire les
impôts la classe moyenne
on en demande en plus aux mieux nantis
on va et vestiaires dans notre parti il
faut savoir rapidement vous vous dites
les deux sens mais les plus fous les uns
voulaient les impôts payés plus de taxes
et pour que la classe moyenne peut sans
payer moins
ce que monsieur mulcair ne fait pas mais
lui va augmenter l'impôt des grandes
corporations puis vous n'allez pas là
non parce que honnêtement notre économie
a besoin d'investissements dans une
création sur la coalition je suis un
comme tout libéral toujours ouverts à
travailler avec d autres partis visant
l'importation une organisation une
structure former une coalition formelle
absolument pas mais je sais que les
canadiens vont s'attendre à ce qu'un
gouvernement fonctionne pour bien
gouverner donc pote pas de coalition
formel n'ait accord possible à corps à
corps à corps non non parce que de
travailler sur les différents enjeux sur
la question d'unité nationale sur la
question de l'économie sur la question
de nos relations à l'international
c'est trop important d'avoir un
gouvernement cohérent avec un plan pour
faire croître l'économie et pas juste
des promesses qui sont différentes dans
chaque partie du pays comme monsieur
mulcair
monsieur alpe à l'époque a eu ni la
droite et il est au pouvoir depuis neuf
ans parce qu'il a réussi à unir la
droite
beaucoup de gens se posent et moi c'est
une des questions qu'on me pose le plus
monsieur trudeau c'est pour une paix des
les libéraux ne sont pas arrivés à un
accord à une fusion appelez ça comme
vous voulez pour offrir une alternative
aux conservateurs
si vous perdez si monsieur mulcair pères
le 19 octobre
parce que c'est pas inévitable j'ai
confiance que les canadiens le 19
octobre vont choisir le meilleur
gouvernement vont choisir un parti qui
présente un plan réel et des députés qui
vont être des voix forte pour leur
communauté à ottawa et ça et j'ai
énormément confiance dans notre capacité
de faire les bons choix mais vous
répondez pas est-ce que non mais ce que
vous regardez le teaser est passé parce
que c'est impossible dans votre boîte de
gérance et un travaillent ensemble
pour survivre le parti libéral a
toujours travaillé avec différents
partis je pourrais pas travailler avec
le parti conservateur maintenant parce
qu'ils ont tellement
la cour y travailler avec le parti gpd
avec d'autres partis qui proposent des
deux projets de loi qui sont légitimes
pour le canada d'ailleurs on devrait
avoir un parlement où il ya beaucoup
plus de débats beaucoup plus de
compromis beaucoup plus d'amendements au
projet de loi pour bien vente yves rossy
de gouverner ce que nous font et ce
qu'ils nous font c'est un bon
gouvernement transparent et ouvert sur
trudeau j'ai regardé comme beaucoup de
canadiens le premier débat du mais crise
j'étais surpris vous allez m'expliquer
puis des gens au québec qui ont été
surpris que ou facile et détours pour
ramener la question référendaire
ce n'est pas à l'agenda les gens on
parle pas mais moi je me suis péladeau à
part bien sûr mais pourquoi j'ai fait
des détours pour revenir sur le seuil 10
ans et 5,75 en plus on ne sut mille 15
ans par monsieur 1440 jamais rien su
mulcair a vanté lors de la saint jean
baptiste
la déclaration de sherbrooke qui dit
qu'il n'est pas en accord avec les neuf
je suis d'accord avec 50 plus c'est
qu'il n'est pas d'accord avec la course
ou pour cet enjeu là ça fait dix ans
qu'on nous la prairie minn et ses
projets de charger la canebière
pourquoi c'est dans le programme de
monsieur mulcair
c'est lui qui en a parlé j'ai moi je
trouve que monsieur mulcair qui en
parlent seulement au québec et ailleurs
au canada
un besoin de se faire dire que écoute
après dix ans d'un premier ministre qui
cherche la chicane avec la cour suprême
s'ils vont en avoir un autre les gens
sont mieux de le savoir en quoi il est
en désaccord avec la cour suprême 26
d'accord mais vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir monsieur trudeau qu'au québec ça
fait pas mal consensus unanimité olympe
aux mollahs consensus tous les partis à
l'assemblée nationale lise les
intellectuels les groupes de pression
les gens s'entendent 50 points comme en
écosse c'est réglé c'est ça la loi
vous le savez je vous ferai pas changé
d'idée je vous demande même pas on a
déjà eu cette discussion là mais
pourquoi vous ramener sain débat vous
savez qu'au québec
vous perdez des points quand vous menez
la salle il n'y a pas énormément
québécois qui vont être surpris qu'un
trudeau défend l'unité nationale
québécois qui vont être déçus que vous
n'acceptiez pas la règle 50 plus cher
que j'accepte le principe mis en place
par la cour suprême du canada de façon
unanime y compris les trois juges du
québec qui dit on est dans tes les
politiques non mais on est dans un
terrain où réellement dans ma vie de
tous les jours tant que député de
papineau les gens parlent pas de
constitution du site
donc je sais mais monsieur mulcair veut
nous replonger dans une méga rondes de
débats constitutionnels
avec son plan de changer le lieu
d'abolir le sénat et de change
d'éliminer la loi sur la clarté une
dernière question a pris le temps file
la sécurité la sécurité d'un thème
important où j'ai pour ces 51 nous
appuient le projet de loi de six venant
peu qui veut donner plus de pouvoir aux
services policiers etc
mais vous êtes contre les bombardements
je repose la même question que j'ai
posée à monsieur mannequin la semaine
dernière commence
qu'est ce qui pourrait vous mieux
justifier une intervention militaire
musclée
sinon que ces horreurs que l'on voit
tous les jours et vous voyez la masse de
réfugiés en europe
c'est une catastrophe sur le plan et
vous vous dites non on bombarde rapport
assez pour expliquer deux éléments
d'abord je suis en faveur faveur de ses
51 dans ces éléments qui augmente la
sécurité des gens mais je suis je me
suis engagé à changer ce projet de loi
pour s'assurer qu'on est en train de
défendre les droits des canadiens parce
que monsieur un peu pense pas qu'on a
besoin de faire plus pour défendre les
droits et libertés
mais monsieur mulcair de l'eau par pense
pas qu'on a besoin de faire plus pour
défendre la sécurité
le parti libéral cette autorité le parti
qui fait les deux ensemble mais à ce
niveau là qu'ont été clair bombardements
bombardements le parti libéral a
toujours appuyé
quand c'était dans l'intérêt du canada
dans l'intérêt de nos valeurs 2e une
chance avec une chance de réussite
d'intervenir dans le monde en
afghanistan au kosovo
partout on change russes et jeudi que le
plan de bombardements de monsieur harper
a n'a pas été bien expliqué nabob
étaient bien encadrés ce que vous
pourriez
georges eddy décidé généreux faisait la
preuve que sa red bull et j'ai déjà
changé j'ai pas changé d'idée mais
depuis le début je dis que nos forces
armées se devrait d'être impliqués dans
la lutte contre l etat islamique mais en
faisant ce qu'on a très bien fait en
afghanistan
c'est à dire que la formation sur le
terrain si vous êtes premier miné ses
des généraux vous dise
et vous avez des rapports disant oui
mais c'est vrai que les bombardements
c'est pas parfait mais ça aide à réduire
la progression de l'oeil est ce que vous
êtes capable de changer d'il ya déjà
énormément de pays en train de faire ses
bombardements des arabes
s'il y avait des vraies preuves que les
bombardements c'est parfait monsieur
après on aurait parlé or il en parle
n'est pas transféré pour vendre ils ont
élu sinon vous a plu ou six mois
maintenant il est gêné dis clairement
nous allons arrêter cette mission de
bombardement mais nous allons continuer
de faire partie de la lutte contre
l'état islamique
le match terminé bonne fin de campagne
sur l'ambiance mai prochain